welcome everyone as you can see there's
a lot of snow in germany this is really
a condition that is pretty much
unparalleled for years there hasn't been
that much snow here in germany
so welcome to another episode of firm
learning my name is heinrich and on my
channel i want to help you
to be successful in the first years of
your career today we are going to talk
about a question that is really crucial
for every professional services context
doesn't matter if you want to talk with
colleagues with clients
the question often is how can you be
trusted
how do you build trust with your clients
and with your co-workers
and there is one concept one framework
that is frequently taught
in consulting onboarding programs in
training programs of mbb
consulting firms like mckinsey bcg and
bain
and this is the so called trust equation
the trust equation this is what we're
going to talk about today
i'm going to explain to you what the
trust equation is all about
but don't worry i will not keep it
purely theoretical
but i will give you very tangible advice
on how you can translate that to your
daily work on how you can build trust
in your work environment and again it
doesn't really matter whether it's
consulting
industry banking trust this will be
applicable for many contacts
so stick in here with me and let's get
started
so what is the frost equation to my
knowledge the trust equation was first
described by david
meister in his book the trusted advisor
it shows a basic relationship
what the factors are they contribute to
you building trust
with another person and more
specifically that the other person
actually trusts you and according to
this equation there are three factors
that increase
trust but there's also one factor to
reduce trust so let's briefly go over
these factors but the later will also
provide very tangible
examples on how to make this actionable
to you on what you can do to actually
build and increase trust according to
this framework so let's go one by one
credibility this is about the knowledge
are you perceived as somebody who is
credible who knows his or her stuff who
really knows what he's talking about
second reliability is more about your
actions can you be trusted that you will
actually do what you promised to do
will you deliver are you reliable third
intimacy and this is about building a
personal relationship a
bond with the other person does the
other person feel like he or she is
close to you
of course a bond helps to build and
develop trust
and then the fourth factor
self-orientation is rather something
that reduces trust
it will hurt you it will undermine the
relationship that you are building with
a person
are you perceived as someone who only
thinks about him or herself
can you be trusted that you also have
the other person in mind or will you do
things only to the extent that they
actually benefit you directly this is
the trust equation
and i understand if you know say hey
that's a bit theoretic what does this
really mean for me how can i really put
this to life to build trust and this is
what we will dig into
right now and the first factor is
credibility and this is indeed
maybe the most obvious one of course you
want to be perceived as credible you
want to be perceived as a domain
expert as a knowledgeable practitioner
and so in industries like consulting
especially for the most junior
colleagues
this can of course be an issue because
often you will be a young graduate
fresh out of university how will you be
the domain expert for a certain topic of
a project that you are staffed on so now
a couple of things that i did when i was
staffed as a young colleague on a
project where maybe i didn't feel too
comfortable about the topic that was
being covered so the first
is fact packs in many professional
services firms you will have access to
knowledge to databases to industry
reports download lots of these
read them potentially also in your free
time on the weekend
make sure that you have a solid
understanding about the challenges that
the industry is facing and last but not
least
ask your leadership the responsible
partners to provide a little talk in the
first week of the project often the
senior partners already covered the
client for several years they really
know the organization inside out and
sometimes they will do this on their own
initiative but often it also can help
just to ask them for it
and then in most cases they will be
happy to just spend one or two hours
giving you a download of everything that
they know about the client about the
topics that are top of
mind of the board members of that client
and of course this can be tremendously
helpful for your engagement the second
element of the trust formula is
reliability
what can you do so that the client
perceives you as reliable and i remember
my very first
project at mckinsey where i got a little
tip from a project lead and she told me
heinrich is actually pretty easy just on
purpose put yourself in situations where
you can prove
to the client that you are reliable so
next time you sit together with a client
tell him or her okay i will send this
document to you until tomorrow
10 am or say okay today at 7 pm
in the evening i will give you a call so
make these little commitments these
little promises
and then of course make sure that you
really fulfill them if you commit to
give a call at seven
don't call it five past or ten past
seven but call at 7. if you promise to
send the document until next day 10 am
do that and don't send it at 11 am it is
often these
little things that will help you to be
perceived as reliable and trust me now
from my current experiences working as a
cto in a german retail company it
happens to me
every single day that people tell me i
will call you tomorrow this time
i will send you this at this time and
then people don't do that this
really happens every day and it drives
me crazy
and of course this is exactly what leads
to these impressions that i do not
really trust these people that i do not
find these people to be reliable so
don't be like that but
prove on a regular basis that you are
reliable and this indeed
will lead to trust the next part of the
trust equation i want to talk about
today
is intimacy how do you build intimacy
with
colleagues with co-workers and here i
have two tips for you to share
and the first is a tip that i got from a
former project lead that i worked with
and he told me well heinrich what you
can do is whenever you visit a client
in his office or now today even in a
video call if you hang out on zoom on
teams or whatever
just look at the things that are in the
office of this person
and ask him or her about that wow that's
an interesting picture
that's an interesting little statue what
is it all about this
is great to build some intimacy with
your client
because this offer will spark some very
personal stories
very personal things that you will learn
from that person and the second tip to
build
intimacy is really just to share some
personal stories of yours
talk about what you do in your free time
talk about some hobbies of yours
let the other person know you open up a
little bit
this again will build some relationship
some bonding
and of course this often also encourages
the other person
to share something personal as well and
this is then often the starting point of
a deeper more
intimate relationship with this
colleague or client that you want to
bond with
and now the last factor is
self-orientation and again this is
something that you don't want to be
perceived
as this is something that will hurt the
trust relationship that you want to
build and this is indeed a tricky thing
in many professional services context
because of course the majority of the
people on the client side that you work
with on an everyday basis
this is not really the people that you
work for but you need to work with them
to get something from them to get some
inputs to get data you know from the
perspective of these people it's very
easy for them to feel used they will
often and easily get the perception that
the whole relationship is a one-way
street where you want to have something
from them but you do not really care at
all about these guys you do not care at
all how he or she is doing whether what
you are doing is contributing in any way
to her work and of course sometimes this
is hard to avoid but i found it always
very worthwhile especially with those
people where you know that these will be
key contact people for you where you
know that your project success will
really depend on the relationship that
you will be able to build with that
person make it a point to always
also give back do things for this person
that maybe you don't need to do
ask this person the beginning hey what
are you working on is there anything i
can help with maybe you can help this
person with an analysis that this person
is doing
try to do a little favor for this person
another problem that often arises in
these contexts is that especially as a
young consultant you feel like that you
want to put yourself into the center of
attention so maybe you were co-creating
a certain result with a client now you
want to present something in front of a
senior leader of that organization and
here it can often be so powerful for the
relationship to pre-discuss this with a
client and let the client do the whole
presentation let's make the client the
winner here help him or her to shine in
front of his or her leaders
but this you will not be perceived as
self-oriented this is really one of the
best ways just to build these
relationships and create these
situations where after you've done
something like this a couple of times
then the client at some point will also
be willing and happy to potentially also
help you out when you really need
something maybe you will be at some
point where you very urgently need
something from that person and then
often this person will also be willing
just to sit there late at night to
create this on the same day just to help
you
of course just the opposite might be
true if you're not able to build this
trusting relationship so i hope you
found these tips insightful
as always if you have any question just
leave me a comment below in the comment
section
and i will do my very best to answer
every single comment that you write
and as you know every comment that you
leave also helps me
with the youtube algorithm with the
youtube system so this is much
appreciated
in addition to that if you took any
value out of this video at all
hit the like button for the youtube
algorithm and of course also subscribe
to the channel to stay up to date on all
my content
also have an instagram my handle is firm
learning there you can see even more
content from me
also have a mailing list link to that in
the video description
i now want to say thanks to all the
members of the channel you are really
doing a considerable contribution to my
work
this is much appreciated and if you want
to learn about what it's all about to
become a member and what perks would be
in for you
hit the join button next the subscribe
button to learn all about this
so thank you guys my name is heinrich i
release a new video
every single saturday on this channel so
cheers good weekend to you
and talk to you soon